every day millionaires is a new series
on our YouTube channel be sure and check
it out at dave ramsey the Dave Ramsey
show on YouTube and Chris Hogan our
resident expert on everyday millionaires
drop by article hit the news line this
morning I picked this up on USA Today
Chris the number of fidelity 401k plans
with a balance of $1,000,000 or more
jump to a record hundred and fifty seven
thousand in the first quarter up from
one hundred and eight thousand a year
order a year earlier according to the
latest report by fidelity investments
for those of you that don't know
fidelity investments is the largest fund
family out there American Funds is a big
one fidelity is a big one Vanguard is a
big one and so on and so what they're
saying is Chris within the 401k plans
that fidelity manages that basically
they've had about a 50% increase in one
year of 401k millionaires it goes on to
say about three and ten savers increase
their contribution rate over the last
year fidelity found the average 401k
contribution rate is now 8.6 percent as
of the first quarter the highest
percentage in almost ten years and more
employees are putting away are putting
enough away to get the company match
particularly Millennials mm-hmm yay the
average retirement balance savings
balances are now in the six figures
the average 401k balance is a hundred
and two nine at fidelity and this is
representative from fidelity says you
have to be in it for the long haul
you're particularly if you're a
millennial under 40 you're saving for
retirement it's a marathon it's not a
sprint retirees are now wealthier than
any previous generation according to
separate report by United income over
the last three decades the average
wealth among retirees increased over 100
percent to seven hundred fifty two
thousand the share of retirees that are
millionaires also more than doubled over
the same time now accounting for 1 in 6
retirees are millionaires relative to
pass general
the current generation of retirees is
much better off almost sounds like USA
Today is men listening to the show I
think they have I mean because looking
at this Dave and walking through it
talking about that it's over the long
haul you know being able to take
advantage of the company match having
that long-term view
I mean they they're definitely listening
to the show but the good news is is that
I mean fidelity is just one company
right and so there's lots of other ways
it's not necessarily say Society mm-hmm
Americans are you know the number of
millionaires jumped 50 percent in one
year but within 401ks at fidelity they
did that's pretty amazing that is
amazing and for people out there to
understand the 401 KS and 403 B's these
are places for you to not just put your
money but these are places to grow your
money and so don't look at it where
you're just throwing money you're
putting money there to grow time and
compound interest working on your 401k
or 403b all that makes good things
happen my friends well you pick out the
four mutual funds we talked about during
the growth and income aggressive growth
and international you'll get great
returns and they're saying here that you
know an increasing number of people are
putting in at least enough to get their
match and our smart dollar team works
with corporations all over the all of
the United States where they're putting
you know with the HR team they're
working with the HR team the 401k team
to get more and more employees out of
debt and into their 401k plan so we're
helping them bring their 401k plans back
to health and a lot of 401k plans have
too much debt borrowed against them not
enough people participating they the
stupid auto and roll thing so they got
people didn't even know they were
participating and and it's not giving
them what they want instead we teach
people get control of their money step
up get that match stay in there it's a
marathon not a sprint and the smart
dollar teams seen some really powerful
returns on that when companies are doing
that because it looks just like what
this articles talking about well it
really does then Dave I don't know
anybody out there that's a part of a
company if you're there you want to take
care of your team members and the best
way to help them is to take care of
their financial future help them to
understand how money really works
smart dollars our program where Dave and
Rachel and I we teach people the
realities of the program how do you
budget how do you get yourself out of
debt
you start to understand how money works
and companies out there Dave that have
signed up are experiencing the benefit
because people aren't distracted with
money problems they're focused on doing
their job I think your entire inspired
movements catching on three in ten
savers increase their contribution rate
over the last year and I mean it gets me
excited and also Millennials yeah the
fact that Millennials are listening Dave
and they're putting money in and they're
gonna leave it alone they're not gonna
take it out for a home downpayment it's
not money for a wedding this is for your
dreams and so putting that money in and
allowing it there now Dave we still have
some teaching to do because people
aren't at 15%
yeah we've been telling them right 15%
of your household income is what you
need to get to and that's the place to
be so you get there to get out of debt
and have your emergency fund employed
you give yourself a raise yeah get these
out of your life get discover out of
your life and let's start to get more of
your money build up an emergency fund
and start to invest this money but this
is almost contrary to this whole wealth
inequality thing that's running around
out there that oh you know the average
American is you know the wages are
stagnant and we're all stuck and we're
dying and it's all phony social we need
socialism and Anarchy and all this
whining that's going on and yet over the
last three decades the average retirees
wealth at retirement has increased 100
percent that's the average that is not
just the 1% that's not the wealthy you
know it's not that you know the rich guy
getting richer it's not some trust-fund
baby these are people doing this with
their retirement plans becoming wealthy
somebody's telling a fib Dave I mean if
you're talking about that there's it's
inequality and people can't do it little
man can get ahead we're seeing the proof
of it that they can get they can get
ahead they just need to work a plan that
actually works now I have to emphasize
this because there are all kinds of
get-rich-quick schemes out there I'm not
talking about those things okay I'm
talking about a plan that actually works
and that's Financial Peace University
we've helped millions of people in the
last 25 years to take control get out of
debt and start to invest and it's one of
those things Dave I love when you talk
about crock pots versus microwaves
because that's the reality of it putting
that money there and letting it sit
letting it grow
that's the crock pot method
don't try to microwave your financial
future get control of it and do it the
right way yesterday we did the
millionaire the everyday millionaires
theme hour and every single one of them
had between a 1 and a 2 million dollar
net worth that called in and almost
every one of them were right around
two-thirds of their net worth was their
401k one third was their paid off house
and so they're sitting there with a
million and a half dollar net worth as
an example $500,000 in unpaid for house
and a million dollars in their 401k and
that's what this exact article is also
revealing it's the exact same numbers
people are winning when they make the
choices they really are Dave I'm gonna
tell you that don't tell anybody but
this is in the research I did you know
we did the largest study on millionaires
over 10,000 of them we studied and guess
what guess what the number one cause for
their wealth building was what 79
percent of millionaires reach
millionaire status through their company
sponsored 401k 79 79 percent their
company so the smart dollar thing when
they're going in teaching their
employees that makes their 401k work if
you want to be a millionaire used to
company 401k that's right
seventy nine eight out of ten off that's
right of the millionaire's Wow they did
it low and steady Wow overtime and and
so for me that's one of those things
where I go they got the match they laid
out in the mutual funds and they left
the money there didn't pull it out
didn't get along again you know none of
them said that we avoided the expenses
of the mutual funds by doing some kind
of passive investing that I read about
on the internet all of them just stepped
up put money in 100 percent of time they
invested money and that's what got them
there I mean that's that's pretty
amazing when you think about it really
is and they did it consistently over
time meaning they got themselves out of
debt they use the 401 K and they stayed
focused on the plan mm-hmm it leads to a
destination and so for you listeners out
there if you're wanting to get to
millionaire status if you're wanting to
make sure you can secure your financial
future you need to get involved involved
in your 401k I mean we've these are
three or four pieces of data that are
really strong in the last 24 hours and
we've
into here one was the actual callers
yesterday on the everyday millionaire's
theme hour this article saying it's
jumped to a record of a hundred and
fifty-seven thousand millionaires at
fidelity over one hundred and eight
thousand a year ago and then this piece
of information you just laid out
seventy-nine percent of the millionaires
we studied use their 401k to get their
you know get Chris Hogan's book retire
inspired if you companies want to get
your your 401k sealed get in touch with
smart dollar we already do this Chris
thanks for dropping by to talk about
thanks you have thanks for having me
Dave Chris Hogan number one best-selling
author of the book retire inspired and
Ramsey personality I'm Dave Ramsey